there's a video that's gone viral right
now
and it's a video from
some school where some kids are beating
up another kid and the kid there's one
kid in particular who's beating up one
other kid in particular and then there's
a group of kids standing around one of
whom is filming and
in the video the kid who the kid beating
up the other kid is black the kid
getting beaten up is white and the kids
all standing around and filming all seem
to be black as well it's a horrible
horrible
video but it is basically everywhere on
the internet right now
you see the kid
kid throws the poor kid's head into a
wall kid's now grabbing his neck
he walks up kicks him in the face i mean
just savage
absolute animal kind of behavior
and it's uh you know the k the kid who's
the kid who's doing the beating
is is bad enough savage enough
in a way the kid who's filming it is
even worse
maybe the kid who's doing the beating is
just like some rabid dog who can't
control his own emotions but the kid
who's doing the filming is clearly much
more methodical about it has thought
this thing out and it's just awful your
heart breaks for this poor little kid
who's been beaten up
uh i hope the kid is okay obviously we
can all pray for the poor little kid
who's beaten up and we can hope that
justice is done for the savages who are
who are committing the crime
the reason i bring it up though
the reason i bring up specifically the
racial terms
is
we all know for a fact that if if the
races were reversed
not only would this
be spoken of on all of the news networks
this wouldn't just be going viral on the
internet this would be on every news
network the president would speak about
it there would be a national month of
mourning there would be riots in the
streets
there would there might be a
presidential address
there might be a presidential address
about how we need to have a national
conversation about race and right we all
know
that that would happen and and the
reason i bring this up again is not
to point out the hypocrisy and say you
know if the rules were reversed right
that that's that's actually not my point
here
because
could you imagine if the roles were
reversed is how conservatism is going to
die because it's just of course it's
hypocritical the left knows it they
don't care that's yes uh-huh you're not
you're not telling them anything they
don't already know
the reason i mention it the reason i
even show that awful clip
is because
because of the strength of narrative
because if if the roles were reversed
it's not just the libs who would
cynically exploit it
in the way that they're ignoring this
clip
you would feel it too
you conservative people
you conservative people all throughout
the country see the shining sea in every
city and every state of every race of
every demographic group you would feel
it a little bit too
such is the power of narrative this is
how there were plenty of
people who were kind of center-right
friends i know who would call themselves
conservatives
who started to get sucked into the
george floyd stuff who posted the blm
black square
who fall into this because it is the
narrative that is drilled into us
everywhere from every cultural
institution and from the government and
in our education system and in the media
and just everywhere
and so we might know
yes statistically this isn't real
statistically
racist cops chasing down black men it
just doesn't exist it's lock that one
away with bigfoot it's totally not real
we know we we we know that on an
intellectual level but such is the power
of narrative
even the centrists
even the
center right even some conservatives
would feel that instinctively i'm glad
you like that clip now here's what i
need here's what i'm begging for i need
you to ring the bell and subscribe get
all the notifications for this show
hopefully get around some of the
algorithmic issues that our overlords
are are inflicting upon us and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
you